hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game it was played a few days ago
actually it's a game from round one of
the Phaedo World Team Championship I
thought I'm not gonna be showing it
since it's a game from round one and we
only started covering this championship
from round three but as a lot of you
have been suggesting it in the comments
I decided to check it out and after
after I saw it I decided to definitely
show it as it's some next-level alpha0
attacking chess so I'm sure you're gonna
enjoy it it's played between India Board
one Bhaskaran audubon who's been having
an excellent tournament so far and the
niels grand alias we also saw a very
nice game played between grinnellian I
teach in the previous video if you
haven't seen that I will put a link to
it in the description below so feel free
to check that out as well but without
further ado let's just check it out and
I don't have a photo of this match up
unfortunately but I do have this
excellent photo of Alexander district so
you're more than welcome to check it out
also it's by David Lada the official
photographer of the championship just
look at that detail I mean it's it's
just an amazing photo so there you have
it not really having anything to do with
this game but you know yeah we you know
we have to make do but okay getting back
to this game Adi bongos for efore we
have e5 Knight to f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to c4 the Italian game is on the
board we have Knight to f6 the two
Knights defense and now nice the g5 this
is an excellent move going for the f7
square but it was not played in this
game in this game
Adi one goes for d3 and okay we have
Bush of the c5 Audubon castles and now
d6 and c3 it's a very nice line for
white in the Italian game it was used
plenty of times in the 2018 blitz
championship more notable games are
correctly news that against the sweedler
Anand also won a very nice game in this
line but okay
h6 by black we have rook to e1 not not
worried about any Knight to g4 ideas
going after the f2 pawn even if the
black decided to do this let's say
Knights the g4 then white can always
just reply Defour or simply
walk with rook to e2 and the white will
be fine that he will kick away the night
next one perhaps with h3 and the black
doesn't really do anything with this
move
so here black castles and we have Knight
B to d2 white goes for this
well well-known maneuver in the Italian
game from their knights and goes to e3
to g3 and depending on what black plays
the the white knight will decide where
to go we have a 592 f1 Bishop to e6 and
now Bishop to b5 here would this Bishop
to b5 move the knight on c6 is attacked
and with this move
well white would definitely enjoy
eliminating the knight doubling black
spawns and also with this by removing
the knight white is fighting for the
center as the knight is one of the
defenders of the d4 central square
Knight to e7 black doesn't allow this
and now white can just push before he
didn't capture the night but he pushed
it away he captures C captures and now
Bishop to b6 white now has a very nice
Center and the knight now comes to g3
from there the knight can go either f5
to h5 he he can just stay there
defending d4 square you know a nice
square for the knight black pushes d5
challenges White's very strong center
here with E 5 and now Knight to e4
Knight captures pawn captures on d4 and
rook captures on e4 and this position
has been reached before one of the more
notable games last year was played in
2018 in German Bundesliga were Maxime
erosion played against the violent in
Dragunov and they're gonna played Queen
to d5 and he was able to defeat much
higher rate in Maxime Washington with
this Queen to d5 move but here instead
of Queen to d5 we have c5 this is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
so it seems a grand alias was very very
much prepared for this for this line and
of course white is up a pawn for now but
black attacks
white center d5 pawn seems to be
overextended and of course you cannot
capture or do anything as the queen of
d1 is undefended so here with Bishop to
d3
now comes Bishop to a5 forcing a trade
of light square Bishop rook to f4 with a
double attack on the bishop
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
just see captures on d4 and it's a very
nice move black captures back the pawn
and white it doesn't really have the
option of capturing yet another pawn
because just Knight to g6 attacks the
rook and b5 pawn and if rocky for just
Knight captures here and you cannot
capture it because Bishop captures on d4
just attacks the rook and well to make
matters worse if you try and save the
route then capture send you even lose
the Queen so a lot of a lot of poison to
this idea so you cannot capture it black
is very well prepared here and playing
excellent chess rook the g4 by white now
trying to pressure the King side Queen
to d7 and now the Queen wants to come to
e6 but also the Queen is riemann averted
with an attack against the rook h3
defending the rook and now quinta east 6
just you know if you capture my knight
here then i can capture here rook
captures and then just Knight to c6
attacks the rook and the pawn black will
have an excellent game here so after
Queen to e6 we have Bishop to d2 just
developing the the Bishop white also
wants to bring his last rook into the
game
we have rook a to d8 now just you know
the d4 pawn is an excellent passed pawn
so we do want to defend it
rook to e1 and now comes Knight to f5
and this is the moment where the magic
happens where I decided to show this
game it's really just uh just a
wonderful position for you to you know
just enjoy it and also I I do want you
to pause the video here and try to
figure out which move adamant played
here that made me decide to show this
game it's really it's really a
remarkable move so just you know look at
this position and you know try to find
the craziest move in the position
maybe not the craziest but you know just
just a very nice move I'm serious pause
the video here and try to do it I'll
give you a couple of seconds to the side
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations like I said this is some
this is some next-level alpha0 attacking
chess so I'm not even gonna ask
anyone found at the movies Bishop to g5
and it's really an insane move to my
knowledge the engine does not see this
move but after you play that the engine
really actually likes it so it's just a
move it comes with an attack against the
rookin d8 so even if black doesn't
capture it what happens here if you
don't want to capture the bishop
obviously you want to move the rook so
let's say rook d5 but then just push up
to f6 Y just increases the pressure
against the g7 point okay there's still
no danger of capturing it but you do
have to play something rush up to d8
challenges the bishop but now loop to f4
with a double attack against the knight
on f5 and now after G captures rook
captures F captures on e5 rook captures
on e5 you can go rook captures Knight
captures and we have this position where
the material is completely equal White
has an excellent night placed on e5 a
rook on f5 and the well blacks bone
structure is all messed up on the King
side so white would have the advantage
here so this is the idea behind Bishop
to g5 so here grande' lucida sides to
capture the bishop H characters on g5
but this is not where the fun starts
we have Knight captures on g5 and now
what do you do with the Queen
you can go f6 the pony's covering that
you don't want to go in front of the
rook if you go something like Queen h6
then you run into East 6 this is pretty
terrible of course the threat is pushing
the pawn all the way to e7 also you can
capture on f7 if black captures you can
capture with the knight but there's
really no no good defense here for black
for example if you capture white can
even capture with the rook attack the
Queen and the Fluke f6 just capture the
bishop here I have the fruit captures
are you can go Queen c4 check and this
will now be deadly if you move the king
then Queen to f7 will be checkmate if
you move the King than 912 7 wins the
Queen not not a lot of possibilities
here for black
so after this Knight to g5 move we have
Queen to see it just getting the Queen
to safety and here rook to f4 disruptor
4 it's just I'm down a piece and you
know I'm just improving my position it
doesn't matter that I'm down a piece
really just impressive attacking chess
you do have to do
something about this you cannot know the
night because we need seven is the
threat of checkmate so you have to
defend it g6 is played here and okay
there's just g4 now pushing the night
back and this is once again one one of
the critical moments in the game here
you have to go 93 that's the problem you
just grabbed White's very strong piece
but you have to give it back or at least
you have to try and give it back white
of course will not capture it white will
go ecigs again with some threats of v7
and then black can go Queen c2 you will
play a captures on f7 and after rook
captures you will play Queen captures in
c2 now we have this Knight captures
Knight captures on f7 Knight captures
only one night capture son d8 bushel
captors and e8 and we will have this
position where white will have a look
against a knight and the bishop but due
to the you know funny funny position of
blacks pawns the rook will you know have
a fun time collecting them and also
White is up upon for the moment so white
is to be preferred here this was a
blacks best bet this Knight the e3 idea
but black play Knight to e7 and this is
just well a huge blunder that's why
well now you can probably see why
Knights the e3 was better and why Knight
to e7 is a blunder but if you don't
again feel free to pause the video here
and try to figure out how to go about
this position it's actually simple but
it's beautiful in its simplicity so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea for white again I'll
give it a couple of seconds for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are and an excellent
you know you know just an excellent
player I have I don't have really have
any more adjectives for this video but
for the Duke we just want to enjoy the
show a queen to g3 the idea is simple
Queen h4 to h7 this will be checkmate so
you do have to defend it the black tried
there's no good defense against this
black tried came to g7 just preparing to
meet Queen to h4 would rope to h8 but it
doesn't work white just played Queen h4
we look to a trade and now rook captures
on f7 this is what check King has to
move King do it on the move
and now to finish off the attack rook to
h7 and it was in this position that
Neil's grand alias resigned to the game
what if you resign well of course if you
capture then it's just a meeting to
Queen f7 will be checkmate and if you
don't well then there's really not all
that much you can do rook captures rook
is the threat if you try and run away
with the King it doesn't help you just
captures and after Knight blocks you can
just capture here captures and it's
pretty much the same checkmate so not a
lot of ideas you can use here but yeah
that's the game I mean it's really a
beautiful game that Knight to f5 and
then Bishop to g5 just a just a crazy
crazy position I mean if you move the
rook Bishop f6 is coming and the white
will just keep improving the position
and you know have a better game but this
rook to afford this is this is was
always the problem and what just wants
to bring this Knight over here the
bishop on b6 somewhat misplaced in this
position which which seems odd as Black
has this perfectly healthy
really it's defended three times this
past pawn but white just makes it work
so outstanding attack by by a busker an
Audubon who I don't have to remind you
in I believe in 2017 in the tata steel
chess tournament in the masters division
I believe it was the first time that he
faced off against you know the elite
players he played the Kings gambit
against Wesley so with the white pieces
which was just insane of Wesley so was
raided hard and I believe he was over
2800 at a time so I was like wow playing
the the Kings gambit against the 2800
player that's insane
it was a really crazy game it ended in a
draw I haven't made a video on it but I
will put a link into it in the
description below to the PG and just in
case you want to check it out also I
prepared here are the no that's
Alexander II shook here are the
standings after the day's round we
haven't seen any games from today's
round but I will show it tomorrow Russia
again won won a match so Russia for a
moment first with nine points and it
will be hard to catch up artemiev won a
very nice game against Perugia so
against Iran that
that was the match point following India
with seven England with seven USA with
six China with five China finally won
won a match Iran would five Kazakhstan
with four Sweden with four again a
victory for Sweden as a return with
three and Egypt still without a match
point with zero points but yeah still
gonna be gonna be fun and we'll see what
happens
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you're enjoying my
short coverage of the video bro team
championship 2019 I would like to thank
a line of Stefan's primo still is go
ahead David writer Frederick get on and
Patrick a Bowser for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content feel free to suggest games as
you know if you haven't suggested this
one I probably would have missed it and
it would be such a shame because this is
this is brilliant
attacking chess okay I think y'all and I
will see you soon have an excellent rest
of your Saturday